لذلك تحدث الرئيس بايدن عن
حصول الأشخاص على جرعات معززة أه
بعد ثمانية أشهر من اللقطة
الثانية للقاحات mrna ،
هل تعتقد أن ثمانية أشهر يجب أن تكون
علامة صعبة وسريعة ماذا عن
الأشخاص الذين يخططون للسفر
بعد ستة أشهر من اللقطة الثانية ، هل
يفعلون ذلك  ليس سببًا جيدًا كافيًا
للحصول على معزز هذا
المقطع الثالث جيدًا ، أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا النظر في البيانات التي
تظهر عندما تتضاءل المناعة
بالفعل ولم نر بالتأكيد
سوى القليل جدًا من البيانات المنشورة ، إنها في الغالب
معلومات على موقع وزارة
الصحة الإسرائيلية.  القليل من البيانات
القادمة من Mayo Clinic
ومصادر أخرى ، لذا لم
تتح لنا الفرصة حقًا لمراجعة البيانات الكاملة
لنقول متى تكون هذه النقطة المحددة هي إعطاء
التطعيم الثالث وأعتقد أن الشيء الآخر
الذي نحتاجه  هل جايك
يعيد تشكيلنا قليلاً ، فنحن نستمر في
الحديث عنه باعتباره معززًا بينما
كنت أعتقد طوال الوقت أن هذا
لقاح من ثلاث جرعات وكان لقاحًا بثلاث جرعات
لأننا  اضطررنا إلى إعطاء
هذين التحصينين الأولين دفعة قوية
على التوالي لمدة ثلاثة إلى أربعة أسابيع فقط
لأننا كنا في أزمة
كنا نفقد ثلاثة آلاف من
الأرواح الأمريكية يوميًا كان علينا أن نطعم الجميع
بشكل كامل ولكن عندما تفعل هذا
النوع من الجدول الزمني
يكاد يضمن أن يكون لديك
مناعة متضائلة في مرحلة
ما وهذا هو السبب وهذا هو السبب في أنه
أصبح لقاحًا من ثلاث جرعات ، والقطعة الأخرى على
الرغم من أننا لم نر ما إذا
كنا نشهد حقًا اختراقًا في
المستشفى ولكننا نشهد الكثير
تتراجع فعالية العدوى الخارقة
من أكثر من 90 إلى 40 إلى 50 في
المائة ، لكن هذا بالنسبة للعدوى ، هل
نحتاج إلى رؤية هذا الانخفاض في حالات
الاستشفاء أيضًا أو
بسبب الطمع طويل المدى الذي نراه الآن
حتى بين حالات التطعيم المتقدمة لدينا
والتي  نريد
أن نزيد من ذلك في تلك النقطة ، لذا فإن الشركة التي
اجتمعت اليوم
خصصت فقط قدرًا صغيرًا من الوقت
لهذا أه لهذه الأسئلة
التي تقدمت فايزر مؤخرًا للحصول عليها  لذلك أعتقد أن
هذا سيأتي مع اجتماع ecip التالي ،
لذا أشارت شركة Pfizer اليوم إلى
أنها سترسل بيانات اللقاح للأطفال
الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 5 إلى 11 عامًا
في سبتمبر ، وهو الشهر المقبل
، وربما تقدم طلبًا للحصول على إذن استخدام طارئ
لهذا اللقاح للأطفال
في أكتوبر  هذا يعني
أن الافتراض من الناحية النظرية أنهم يحصلون على ما يريدون
لن يحصل الأطفال الصغار على اللقاحات
حتى وقت متأخر جدًا من
هذا العام ، فما الذي يجب أن
يفعله الآباء حتى ذلك الحين
، أعتقد أن الأهم هو
التأكد من أن كل فرد في
الأسرة مؤهل
للتطعيم  احصل على التطعيم الكامل
لأننا نعلم أن الكثير من الأطفال الصغار
يمرضون من آبائهم أو من
البالغين غير المطعمين في
المنزل وأعتقد أيضًا أنه سيكون من
المهم حقًا أن
يكون كل شخص في تلك المدرسة ملثمين عندما يذهب طفلك إلى المدرسة
ويتم تطعيم كل شخص مؤهل